[Music]
so let me start off by saying this video
is definitely going to be a bit
controversial this is my personal
opinion on the matter and have decided
to very generously allow you I suppose
to have your opinion on this topic as
well even though my opinion is is really
the most the most important in this
video I'm going to be discussing the two
that's right there were two actors that
play Dumbledore in the Harry Potter
series the first actor to appear in the
Harry Potter films was this young
gentleman Richard Harris this is
actually a picture of him at 12 years
old if you can believe it
Harris was an Irish actor and singer who
actually turned down the role of
Dumbledore initially he was afraid that
would be all that he was remembered for
remarking I just don't want to be
removed for being in those buddy films
Harris appeared in the first two films
Harry Potter and the Philosopher's Stone
in 2001 and Harry Potter and the Chamber
of Secrets in 2002 he was a spectacular
Dumbledore and in my opinion fit the
book's description of his character
extremely well his calm calculated
demeanor allowed the humble and kind
nature of Dumbledore's character to
shine through not only that but his
physical appearance matched the old
white wizard to a tee after the Chamber
of Secrets Harris tragically passed away
from Hodgkin's lymphoma the new
Dumbledore Michael Gambon was cast as
his replacement four months after his
death while Gambon was also an
exceptional Dumbledore I still
personally prefer Harris please don't
unsubscribe Gambon is an irish-born
British actor who trained under Laurence
Olivier himself while camp one was great
in the role he appeared to come across
as a bit harsher than Harris while still
very kind gentle humble like me sounds
familiar and calculated he seemed to be
a bit rough around the edges he seemed
less like he was on the brink of death
and to me appeared to be a bit too light
on his feet for such an ancient and wise
old wizard while this was never Gambon's
fault there were a few instances in the
films where his character portrayal
greatly differed from the book one of
the most notable examples of these
differences was when Dumbledore asked
Harry about the Goblet of Fire did you
put your name into the Goblet of Fire
Harry
did you put your name into the Goblet of
Fire Harry
Dumbledore asked calmly the film took
one or two liberties with this and well
this was the outcome so yeah pretty
pretty calmly yeah with that being said
that's pretty much all for the video
which of these two old cartridges is
your favorite I love them both but I've
got to give it to Richard Harris please
let me know down in the comment section
below who your favorite Dumbledore was
able to fire Dumbledore said
[Music]